[Applause]
Jason Jason boss it's like looking in a
mirror
it's all good have a seat have a seat
have a seat of Z finally reunited with
your wives to be but we now discover you
know everybody
you've met Regina below yes yes my wife
so many people we have six degrees both
in the DC Universe no yah yeah yeah I
know I know
yeah oh you know she look alike he's
here as well yeah yeah yeah this is this
is this is essentially what you would
look like if you were chopped off at the
knees and never went to the gym
[Laughter]
one of those things that you can't hide
wherever you go you are the doctor
it's okay because these guys didn't know
what it was yeah you could hide
backstage yeah it's an interesting it's
an interesting thing particularly a
Briton but weirdly the show you can't
predict a demographic it's it's all over
the world and so the reason that thing
where you go okay so you know I'm
walking around this place
I don't need my hat and then the oddest
kind of moment will happen and you go oh
maybe they recognize me but if you're me
you have a slight narcissism what you
think everyone's recognizing you that's
such an embarrassing thing happens to me
yesterday the Jew so is it I've always
to got like Oh anyway right basically
what happened so I stood on Oxford Tube
platform yeah and I've always got so you
know like a glass keep coupe you know
like it rather than going to a coffee
shop and get in a new cup
I carry a glass one that are then wash
and reget malate and so I got I got my
empty cup and I was just stood at down
stuff and an elderly gentleman was
walking towards me on the platform I was
just so I just just want to get the tube
recognised then he had his arm out and
his arm came into my space and on the
tube on the platform it's crowded and
it's a bit I don't know I just got the
candle I I were doing a bit aggressive
unnecessarily and actually what he was
doing was he when a sir I thought you
wanted money anyways
[Applause]
I was like some make eye contacts I can
tell this story you can't hide you can't
put ask I mean but yeah I I mean I've
seen you in a gym I got a public gym so
do you get you get bothered all the time
all the time yeah how do you gone out
the window how do you workout in the gym
if people to constantly give me up to
you
just be nice say hello get a-movin but
fame is a funny thing right so you give
that story for you well that will be
like the constant anchoring reminder
right like how cool Fame is but also
never like I don't have the stress you
have though because I think the thing is
if you if you are 5 or 6 and you've got
a hat on and you dressed like a most the
time a teenage boy in a baseball cap
headphones on head down I catch the bus
and the I catch the bus on the subway
every single day because I'm not in
anyone's eye line like that but I
imagine you there is something about if
if you're you you can't you're 7 Kevin's
had weird you've had weird fan well what
happens if you're 3 foot 2
- I'm sorry good mood Ken Brown is going
to give us a little bit of forum before
we do this if you do your faceoff do
your faceoff come on come on
okay off you go
[Music]
[Applause]
the husband because he always delivers
it's the undisputed heavyweight champion
of the world
[Applause]
they call him Korea the Korea because he
sometimes delivers unless he gets stuck
in traffic
[Applause]
you know first let's have you I thought
that was gonna be heavier okay
okay you go first you mind the cameras
here we go so golf
[Applause]
well you might miss it as well
hey the Bell
don't talk about it there but now we can
talk about at poor old Thor yeah in that
film he's sort of he did eat his
feelings definitely ate his way through
some pictures but that you didn't do
that oh no that was my full Raging Bull
Oscar attempt I mean it's a fat suit
lose it now as much remarkable thing
it's a yeah oh good it's a prosthetic
like takes kind of thing which literally
I would slip into it weighed about 60 70
pounds was that 30 40 kilograms with a
zip up the back and they're taking
photos of my body and then every little
screw of the hair or freckle or whatever
the hell that was on that thing it was
that's my body and in like six months
time like Thor was depressed but we was
it depressing walk for you walk here
mind like that I was so much fun treat
you differently
I said yeah every time I step toward the
catering truck they were like no no no
no we were we were doing an interview
yesterday and the journal it for Good
Omens and the journalist said ask me
were you wearing a fat suit for it
this doesn't zipper Bucci she did him
afraid she didn't really recover from
that moment no never so quickly did you
get the pregnant lady thing where people
was want to touch your stomach you got a
lot of cuddles I've had she's had three
kids and often you know they're pregnant
like the belly rub in the supermarket
and Robert Downey got me a fair share
everyone wanted to cuddle me I feel like
Santa Claus yeah
and that's when we team up and we sort
of become best buds on and off screen
[Laughter]
and we've had these elemental creatures
Jake Tom it sounds that was quite
unsympathetic to you while you were
filming would you get a little a little
peaky oh yeah we were shooting as well
we were shooting a scene and I got a I
got I got sick I was very nauseous
throughout the day and and in the middle
of the one of the takes I I I threw up
in the middle of the tape and kept going
you know but that's how that's what
acting is all about
I was sitting opposite him and I was
like how is he doing that he's so good
he looks so tortured and so unwell and
so so like like hurt and then he
basically just had a stomach bug and
they actually CGI'd the vomit out of the
shot but if you look in the movie in the
movie and there's my house Malthus just
partially open at 1 I'm kidding
[Applause]
that's the Marvel Universe painting out
the vomit but my eyes were so I'm going
to say because it's true it is a really
funny book I say that because it may not
be initially a parent when you start
talking about what it's about
yes pre-empting my poor salesmanship
because I tend to put people off
anything that's to do with me well
you're very kind to say that it is very
funny but now you need to tell people
what it's about okay and let me do some
damage now so it is about a Gwyneth
Paltrow films called view from the top I
mean which he plays the stupidest this
is the post room you see mister is it's
a real film I saw yeah yeah yes it's a
real film well baccala do I need to see
it literally you do not need to if
you've seen any film you have seen this
film it is very similar to all film
plays a blue-collar worker I don't know
what research she did maybe into Whole
Foods Juana and she dreams of becoming
an air stewardess she becomes one that's
the film can she be an air stewardess
and maintain a loving relationship with
Mark Ruffalo oh yeah no being an air
stewardess a two ownerís she's got to
hand out salty nuts
little blowy things she's got to
demonstrate it's a nightmare
what should she do you're literally the
opposite of on the edge of your seats
you're stop telling me the story
she manages to reconcile with Mark
Ruffalo
despite the salty notes does Gwyneth
know about this okay she's not emailed
me as yet
I don't know she maybe you know in the
middle of the cleanse
[Applause]
just time for a visit to the big red
chair this is very exciting
okay first person in the red chair hello
hello what's your name
Celine hello Celine hi jack what story
have you got for us well this is my
second visit to the red chair actually
oh I was here eight years ago right and
I told a story that I thought was really
good about when I was living in France
and something happened with my daughter
however a certain guest on the sofa that
night really did not like my story and
he was rather rude he actually said is
that the best story she could come up
with who does she bloody think she is
funnily enough my daughter met this
person at a night club recently oh my
god it's me
[Applause]
I sent you a message didn't I you did
apologize I know I'm so sorry
that was
[Music]